[Music]  suena morning's a45 we got to talk about  what's happening in Chicago  everybody's watching this viral video  this guy in a hoodie - call him - Grim  Reaper stop the carjacking is he right  for taking the law into his own hands  he's become a folk hero what about the  shooter the men who did it are out there  so there's nothing that you can do is  that what you're saying if a man really  wants to protect force his I want to buy  a gun he has to do it for himself  I believe you Joe you're not gonna kill  me no jackass  you got caught in some crossfire dice  the ice-cream man can't walk to school  if they don't work for you who are you  your last customer cock-blocked and pay  to work I'll say they called him a  guardian angel  [Music]  you look much better  getting out socializing hmm not so much  well whatever you're doing keep it up  okay I will  [Music]  [Music]  you